hello everyone this game was played
today
it was the third round of the Isle of
Man international tournament and it was
a very exciting matchup on board One
world champion Magnus Carlsen is playing
against the junior world champion
Jeffrey's hyung if that is how it's
pronounced and well it's a very
interesting game it was I think it was
about equal but world champion is a
world champion so let's see this this
interesting game Carson is white and she
um is Black Knight to f3
we have c5 c3 Knight to f6 d 4e 6 and
Bishop to g5 datoria attack d5 by
Geoffrey III we have h6 Bishop to h4
Knight to c6 Knight B to D to a6 Bishop
to d3 Bishop to e7 Carlson castles and
here we have a knife to d7 offering the
exchange of this dark squared Bishop and
Bishop to g3 is also possible but Carson
captures Bishop captures any 7 we have
Knight captures any 7 and Knight to e5
Carlsen occupies this very nice e5
square with is night and here Geoffrey
goes for a series of exchanges we have
seek after son before he capture son d4
and now Knight captures on e5 d captures
on e5 and we have Bishop to d7 and well
for the rest of the game it will be very
hard for a young Geoffrey to activate
this light squared bishop he has on d7
cousin goes rook to e1 adding protection
to this e5 pawn rook to c8 and we have
Knight to f3 adding even more protection
to the e5 pawn b5 by Geoffrey and we
have h4 and Simon Williams was a very
excited when he saw this when he saw
Harry moving forward we had a 5
preparing before and now a 3 Queen to b6
again preparing b4 and we have Queen to
d2 now pushing be for a C capture some
before a capture some before and now a 4
of course not capturing on before we
have worked to a8 attacking the a4 pawn
and Carlsen plays b3 now completely
locking off the Queen side and he
created this very nice past a porn
and well besides that he is now he's not
allowing Jeffrey to activate this light
squared bishop again because this well a
for pawn stops him from going to be five
if he can go to c6 but he's not really
gonna do much there maybe Bishop the c6
or c8 and then somehow going to a six
could be activate he could activate like
this then maybe exchange this strong
cost and the bishop on d3 so Jeffrey
castles here and we have rook a to C one
rook F to c8 and now h5 here it goes
further
King to f8 and g4 by Carlsen
and I wrote the c3 probably going for
doubling up rooks on the C file and well
depends on what cost in place maybe even
capturing this b3 point but Carson
doesn't allow this he pushes g5
immediately we have H captures on g5 and
now Carson place rook captures on c3 so
b captors and c3 is well of course
necessary and now Queen captures on g5
and what's the idea here the idea of
course is pushing Harry to h6 and in the
world this has to be stopped and how do
you stop this well there are two options
you can go Knight 2 g8 or you can go
Knight to f5 knife to g8 was a better
move but but Jeffery played Knight to f5
thinking probably that if Bishop
captures on f5 and he captures an f5
then this would be good for black as the
Queen from B six would be defending the
h6 square but he missed a very nice
tactic by Carlsen so he did he played
Knight to f5 we have Bishop captures on
f5 e captures on f5 and now the move
Jeffery missed as he was a lot lower on
time than Carson Carson plays east six
and this is a very nice move Carson
sacrifices upon and what he does with
this is that well he cuts off the
Queen's defense of the h6 square and
okay we can capture the pawn with F
captures an e6 but this would weaken
your King even more so Bishop captures
on e6 is played and now of course h6g
captures on h6 and now Carson doesn't
capture the pawn on h6 would check but
he plays a stronger move Queen to f6
not allowing the King to go to e7 to
and also threatening Queen to h8 with
check winning the rockin a8 so well
there are a couple of ways you can try
to stop this but it's not really easy as
for example if if you stop this by some
rook to b8 move for example then this is
well completely winning for white after
night to d4 threatening to capture this
Bishop and for example King to g8 Knight
captures on d6 FK after sandy 6 and now
rook captures on this asari on e6 Queen
to b7 Queen captures on f5 threatening
rook to g6 and well there really is no
defense to this Queen to f7 rook to g6
King to f/8 and well rook to f6 wins the
Queen and black doesn't have enough time
to push the C pawn so after this Queen
to f6 idea
Geoffrey played King to g8 but this well
this turns out to be even worse as
Carlsen plays Queen captures on h6 and
now cost and totally cuts off the king
the King can go back he stuck on g8 and
while Carlson's plan is very simple he
just moves the king the king and rook
goes to g1 and can Jeffrey stop this
well not really
he could have tried for some counter
play with c2 but this doesn't doesn't
achieve much so he tried a queen to be
Queen to b4 going for Queen to g4 check
or maybe Queen to f8 with some ideas but
this all well this is all impossible
because Carson goes King to h1 and there
is no defense against rook to g1 check
and well in this position
Geoffrey resigned the game and the world
champion was able to defeat the Junior
World Champion because the wall with
strongest defense for example Queen to
g4 you don't immediately have to play
rope to g1 for example Knight to e5 and
after Queen to g7 now rook to g1 pinning
the Queen and while this loses the Queen
Queen captures as you want King captures
as you want and you don't really have
time to put this C pawn because the
queen is already protecting c1 so this
is completely winning for white so yeah
a very nice
again by Magnus world-champion Magnus
Carlsen this is round 3 and his three
out of three so he won all of his games
and we'll see we'll see how this
tournament turns out for him that's it
for this game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I'll see you soon